people did not like the initial proposed
reopening plan so literally hundreds
submitted recommendations to the
district for their consideration 8 News
Now reporter Kristen Drummond has been
following the story and is live tonight
in the studio with some of the
suggestions and how the trustees may
actually kind of tweak this plan tonight
Kristen well Denise trusty Danielle Ford
claims more than 650 people offered
various ideas over the last week and one
came in from a CCSD teacher her proposal
focuses on offering classes all year
long instead of students taking 4
courses a semester an idea gaining favor
with the community on social media
recently we tried to stay within the
parameters that they already have for
their plan except make it so that the
kids have all of their classes all year
Kim Ritzer teaches choir at Green Valley
High School been there for 29 years she
disagrees with CCSD wanting to condense
year-long courses into a semester for
secondary students she is taking AP
classes IV classes even special learners
they need to have that information all
year long to help them retain the
information she submitted this
alternative reopening proposal to the
district it keeps the three cohorts of
blended and distance learning but offers
six and eight period schedules for
students to take classes all year I
tried to take the time constraints that
they gave us in their plan and fit all
those classes in an idea for the board
to consider when modifying the current
reopening proposal trustee daniel ford
posted various recommendations to her
website they include not holding classes
and portables and allowing high risk
educators to choose only distance
learning there are a lot of us who would
like to teach online exclusively that
way we could give our full attention to
the online students and it wouldn't be
the classroom teacher trying to do
cohort a B and C an option as the
district tries to find a solution
basically what this comes down to is
what will be safe and what's going to
actually work
now trustee Ford says certain special
education students should receive
priority and have the option to come
back full-time
she suggested those classes be moved to
libraries and larger rooms to maintain
social distancing